-I'm so very happy
you came back, Jack.
Jack Antonoff, thank you
for being here, buddy.
You look great.
I'm excited to get
into this interview
and discuss things with you.
You've had an amazing,
busy year yet again.
-You brought a cheesesteak
backstage that you said
was from the Roots.
-No, I didn't say it was
from the Roots.
-Is that true?
-It was from me, yes.
-Okay, just we'll talk.
But Jimmy walks up with the
cheesesteak, and it was weird.
And he was like,
"This is from Tariq."
And I was like...
-What did you think?
-I thought it was really good,
but I thought...
-It was a bit.
-I didn't plan
to come out and say it, but then
I saw his face and I was like,
check in about the cheesesteak.
-But I don't do bits with you.
When I see you,
I'm all business.
-That's true.
But I've been busy, Jimmy.
-Thank you.
I appreciate
you resetting me up.
No, let's talk about this
because you've been
very, very busy.
I don't know how you have time
to do all this stuff.
First of all, you won a Grammy
for Producer of the Year
for a second year in a row.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, that was awesome.
Come on now.
That alone, you go, wow,
that's a great year.
But you produced three of
the biggest albums of the year.
Lana Del Rey's "Did You Know
That There's a Tunnel
Under Ocean Boulevard."
That's Jack.
1975's "Being Funny
in a Foreign Language."
That was you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Taylor Swift's "Midnights,"
that was Jack Antonoff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
By the way, "Cruel Summer."
Can we even talk about this?
-It's so cool.
-You produced this song.
You co-wrote it
with Taylor Swift,
and now,
that was four years ago?
-Yeah.
-And now it's -- right now,
today, it's the number-one song
for the second week in a row.
-It's -- I'm so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
-What does it feel like?
-It feels like I'm loving where
the music business has gone
because it just melted down into
nothing but what people like.
And you could talk your crap
about this or that,
but just the fans are God, what
they say goes and all those --
you know, when I was younger
and you'd make a record
and you'd say, that's the song
that if you cracked me open
is my soul, right?
-Yes.
-But then you're like, this song
is cool, but that's the song,
and then everyone is saying, no,
this song that you feel fine
about is the one.
And then they tell you,
you've got to get behind
that one
and then you'll get to --
there's just all this --
choosing of singles
is such a -- because
an album is a patchwork,
and I always see it as like
a house with a front door.
And, you know, sometimes
you don't want your front door
painted yellow,
sometimes you want
it painted black,
it painted red.
So the choosing, you guys have
probably been through this,
where someone tells you like,
this is the one and you're like,
I want to feed my family
and I want to --
But also like --
but the new world is just sort
of -- it's over. It's cooked.
You know, the idea of a single
is just what's the song that
if you could get your friends
in a room, you'd play?
And what happened with "Cruel
Summer" is a testament to that.
It was always our favorite song
in the album.
And then with nothing, with
no gas on the fire,
with no one on the business side
doing anything,
just kids started
playing it more
and more and more.
It happened with that song.
It's happened
with a bunch of things.
And I just think the music
business
is in a fun place
for just the work.
-I also want to say
congratulations.
You got married recently to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Margaret Qualley,
who we love.
Yeah.
How was the wedding?
-I feel like I keep
thinking this,
which I was like,
I had this idea,
like, I perform,
so I don't care.
I don't care. I just want to be
married to her.
I don't give a [bleep].
Are we not supposed to curse?
-No, you can do it.
We'll bleep all this out anyway.
-So in my head I'm like --
-We're going to go right
from cheesesteaks to this.
-Yeah, it's like
I don't [bleep] care.
I want to eat a cheesesteak.
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with you?
-I don't know.
The S-word became --
-And I want to [bleep] marry
her.
-No! Hey! Come on!
-And then...
[ Laughter ]
-Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
-Can we just do away with the
no cursing on TV?
-No, we have to have rules,
Jack.
-Okay, fair. So I didn't care.
And I had this idea,
like, I perform,
so I'm not one of these people,
I don't care.
I can do anything, I'm not --
I don't mind being here.
I don't mind being on stage.
It doesn't faze me too much.
And then as soon as I walked
up there, it was the ultimate...
It was the most alone
I've ever been in my life,
in a way, because my bride
hadn't come out yet,
and I'm very into,
like, making bits.
Even the way I came out here
is a good example, right?
Like Jimmy asked a question and
I kind of like -- kind of
like alpha'd it a little bit
and turned it
and did
the cheesesteak thing, right?
It was a little like -- I'm just
pushing the attention away.
-What's real in your world,
Jack?
-And so I'm always pushing away.
And it was the first time
I was just sort of frozen,
and it felt like
30 years of cynicism
was exiting my body and...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
And you're standing there
and everyone's looking at you
and this is it, bud.
-Yeah, it was --
-Let's go.
I need my missing --
my other half.
-But it was beautiful
and it was every cliché
and I kind of melted
and broke in a very sweet way.
And what I...
haven't felt that way
since the cheesesteak really.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But it's a big deal.
And I know you guys are both --
-It's a huge deal.
And I also like --
Is this really fun?
-I saw your mom in the hallway,
and I said to her last time --
-What'd you say to her?
I said,
"What? Are we back at the --"
I said, "What? Are we back
at the concert?"
-Yeah.
-Because the last time
we saw each other,
we were watching you perform
at Radio City Music Hall,
and you were fantastic.
-You came in hot.
-I did come in hot.
-Because you were --
I think it -- Is Radio City
right there?
-Oh, I came in hot to that show.
-You came in hot
because I think you had,
like, finished the show.
And then all of a sudden
we were about to go on stage,
and you just --
-Did I surprise you?
-It wasn't a surprise,
but you just sort of blew
through the doors and --
-Oh, you know what?
-...and launched into a pep talk
that really --
because it was COVID,
So we were a little bit like --
-I was in the wrong place.
Can I tell you?
[ Laughter ]
I thought I was going to go
right to my seats.
I didn't want to go back
and say hi to you.
-Of course you come back
and say hi.
-I would say back and say
hi to you after the show,
not before the show.
-No, we like that.
-No, you have a thing.
You have a job to do.
I don't want to -- I go --
I ended up in the wrong place,
and all of a sudden
I'm with the band and I'm going
"Let's go, let's huddle up,
let's get in here, guys.
We got to go out there
and crush it tonight."
-It was a funny scene because it
was you, my parents.
-Yes.
-Springsteen.
-Bruce Springsteen.
-And the band.
And then we went and played.
But it was
a weird crew backstage.
-It's weird to give a pep
talk around Bruce Springsteen
because I think he would be
the most peppiest talker.
Like, he'd be like,
"You got to get out there!
1, 2, 3!"
[ Grunting ]
[ as Springsteen ]
You know, the first time,
Jack, the first time
you play Radio City,
you know, you come out and
the curtains close, you know.
But you can you
can hear the lights
and you can hear the crowd.
-Should I be you?
-And you can --
[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Totally ruined the vibe.
-No, no.
-Ruined the vibe.
Hi, guys. Hi, Jack. Hey, man.
Hey, Bruce.
I'm a big fan, man.
-I love Bruce Springsteen
more than anything,
but in life, you can be a Jimmy
or a Bruce, and I'm a Jimmy.
[ Audience awws ]
-But you want to hang
with the Bruce.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but you hang
with the Roots.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was trying to pitch you
some songs backstage
because I always want you
to be getting number ones,
and that's all I care about.
And that's why every time
I see you, I'm all business.
I want to give you
what I'm thinking
and give you
the number-one song.
-What have you got today?
-I got one song.
-Okay.
-It's called "Mexico City."
-Do the Roots know it?
-No, I made it up.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ How are things
in Mexico City? ♪
♪♪
That's it. That's all I got.
[ Laughter ]
You take that and you...
You make, like,
a snowball out of it.
Or it could be a snowball --
No, you don't want to use it
for what, throw things? No.
Jackie,
you carve it with a little --
with a little chisel
and your little hammer
and you carve
that little snowball
into a beautiful ice figurine
of a little German --
No. A little German boy
putting a -- a Dutch boy.
-Putting what?
-A little Dutch boy
putting his finger in a dike...
[ Laughter ]
To stop the leak.
like Hans Christian Andersen
himself.
-Who on this program has
the balls to air that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-What are you talking about it?
We don't cut anything here.
-Have some very guts.
-Yeah. Come on.
-Absolute guts because --
-He's stopping a leak
from a town being destroyed.
-That's nice.
I'll tell you something.
I -- I -- What I liked about
how the song --
Is it called "Mexico City"?
-Yeah, it's a working title.
[ Laughter ]
-What I like about it
is that --
and I'm not even doing a bit --
I heard it and I was like, "Ha."
And then I was like,
how are things in Mexico City?
-Right?
-Well, if you were like,
"I'm in love right now,"
I'd be like, "Okay."
You know,
like, but how are things?
-This could be about
maybe his loved one left him.
-Yeah.
-And restarted her life
in Mexico City.
-I would go --
I would go with,
how are things in Mexico City?
I wouldn't go with
the loved one there.
Maybe the character is broken.
The loved one leaves him
in New York,
and then he's fantasizing
about Mexico City
just like as a place to go.
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
This is what I'm talking about.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No!
-♪ How are things
in Mexico City? ♪
♪♪
-Because life around here
has gotten real weird lately.
Like lately as a soft --
-♪ Latelyyyy! ♪
-Yeah.
And then you see, Jenny left.
-Ooh.
-Yeah. What have you got left?
-Daddy's a [bleep]
-Yeah.
Mommy never been there for me.
-Mommy has never been there.
-Yeah. My job sucks.
-What gives, what gives,
what gives?
-What gives, dude?
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-But I saw a postcard.
-Yeah. On Expedia.
-But then I flip it
that had Guadalajara on it
just so it could be
that part of the song
they're like, "Wait, I thought
we were talking Mexico City."
-Nope.
-Yeah.
-Went to Guadalajara instead.
-And I thought a guy like me?
Question mark.
-Yeah.
-Could it be? Question mark.
-And I got a ticket
and it's one way.
-Where?
-♪ I say ♪
♪♪
No, no, I can't do it again.
I can't do it again.
I can't do it anyway.
Just those little nuggets
I'll keep giving it to you.
And just when they're
number ones, you let me know.
-Oh, the [bleep] lawyer
will let you know.
[ Laughter ]
You wrote it.
-I just want to make sure --
-You think I'm going to steal
your lyric and melody
while you just performed it?
-No, I'm giving it to you.
This is a verbal contract.
It's yours free of charge.
"Mexico City" is your next...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
No, because I don't --
-It's dumb enough that
it could catch.
Like right now,
like part of me...
♪ How are things
in Mexico City? ♪
♪♪
Do you remember it?
♪ Because it round here
has been real weird lately ♪
Ringo fill.
[ Drum solo ]
♪ My dad ain't there ♪
[ Both singing indistinctly ]
♪ How are things
in Mexico City? ♪
♪♪
-Alright, let's think about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're doing a real song.
You're doing a real --
You're here.
Bleachers are performing
"Modern Girl," by the way.
It's a fantastic song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you'll be performing for us
this evening.
-The first time
we've ever performed it live.
And I love that
because it feels like --
There's something that feels
like '60s and classic about it.
Like, we have to,
like, get it together
and we got to play it on TV
and we got to get it right.
Like, the nerves are amazing.
And one last thing before we go.
Last time we were here
was the first show
we ever played after COVID.
So this stage has like
a real energy to us.
It's like we met here
as a band the first time
to play after COVID,
now the first time to play live
on the new album. It's special.
-And I will say I didn't
even get a chance to tell you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That concert I saw at Radio City
was one of the best shows
I've ever seen.
I loved it so much.
You guys were unbelievable.
If you got a chance to see
Bleachers live, go,
run, run, run and you will never
forget it. It's fantastic.
You have great fans.
-The best.
-Jack Antonoff, everyone.
That's what I'm talking about.
"Modern Girl" is out now.
We'll be right back
with Mo Rocca.
Stick around, everybody.